even before you have Gene editing or
embryo selection which has just come
online what we've had is increased
genetic inequality in the last century
why would we have that well women's
education so for the first time women
are getting actually more education than
men and because of their choosiness and
their preferences what's happening is
like a female doctor will just marry a
male surgeon or a really successful male
lawyer intelligence is the number one
trait along which people assertively
made we're already getting increasing
genetic inequalities in the west without
any of this technology what will the
technology do it'll accelerate those
inequalities
what do people misunderstand about what
Eugenics is and means
good question so I would say eugenics in
the broadest sense is any attempt to
harness the knowledge that we have about
heredity to influence the traits of our
kids and in that sense Eugenics is as
old as people and actually much older
um you know any mammal that uses sexual
selection
um ends up in such a situation where
females choose males on the basis of
traits that will partly influence their
own welfare but will also influence the
wealth for their kids and so in a way
Eugenics is as old as you can think as
old as Humanity but the the term dates
back to 1883 and uh Francis Galton who
coined the term and I would say the
reason that that term was invented and
the concepts of eugenics in a really
explicit way made a comeback is that we
had a few things happening in the 1800s
first we get Mendel's experiments on pea
plants so we started getting to know a
little bit more about how heredity Works
a little bit more about what eventually
became called genes Gene the the term
Gene wasn't actually coined until 1905
but we we understood there must be some
unit of heredity that somehow Blends and
recombines to shape traits so first it
starts with Mendel then of course Darwin
comes up with this theory of evolution
by natural selection applied to all
animals not just plants including people
and his cousin Francis Galton who
studied the ready of specific traits
that we care about in humans
intelligence so he wrote a book called
hereditary genius but also just banal
traits like height and skin color and
hair texture and stuff like that and in
fact in fact Francis Galton was the
first to invent twin studies so this is
the idea that we now use in behavioral
genetics where he thought hey here's a
thought experiment what would happen if
we took identical twins and fraternal
twins and raised them apart and just saw
how they ended up like would they be
really similar really different and as
you know fraternal twins share half of
their DNA
identical twins share all of their DNA
and so he thought of this really cool
natural experiment to tease out what
part of our personality our physicality
is due to nature nurture Etc
so so in short what you get is this kind
of golden age in the 1800s where we're
starting to discover how Evolution Works
how heredity works and then this thought
that well maybe we can control it to
some extent in the same way we do for
animals and the same way we do for
plants and you look at what corn used to
look like three thousand years ago it's
this pathetic little weed that yields a
few calories and through selective
breeding obviously we make it more
nutritious more delicious you take those
honey crisp apples like they didn't
start that way there were these sort of
bitter fruits and now they taste like
just pure sugar you know you can amp up
the vitamin C you can do these kinds of
things
and of course it gets dangerous when you
talk about selective breeding for for
people and we'll get into that but it's
pretty clear once you understand
heredity one of your first thoughts is
going to be like okay
how does this influence like my choice
of mates what kind of children I'm going
to end up with and how do those children
end up influencing the traits of people
around us and the overall social welfare
of people
what do you think people are concerned
about when the word Eugenics comes up
obviously Nazism
um and I think this is
partly an innocent explanation it's
partly
um yeah I mean the Nazis did engage in
the worst forms of eugenics you can
imagine which has involuntarily
sterilizing their own citizens and I
mean Germans in this case they actually
sterilized about 300 000 of their own
disabled citizens of course mass murder
that Germans engaged in and so to that
extent we rightly associate it with some
of the evils in the past also American
sterilizations
but there's also a less innocent and I
think
um more Sinister explanation for why we
associate with Nazi Germany and that is
the kind of look left
so they like to take terms and hijack
them such that you can't have certain
kinds of thoughts right so for example
we all have thoughts like I really care
about the traits of my children and to
the extent that I'm engaged in a
long-term relationship I mean of course
what I really care about is the
personality of the other person I'm not
just thinking oh her genes are going to
end up in my kids
but the thought does occur to you that
your kids are going to be something like
you know a combination of the parents
and you know so to that extent like
thinking about heredity and thinking
about how our choices influence outcomes
for our kids is completely natural and a
lot on the radical left want to make
this thought almost impossible to have
and so they call almost anything that
involves genetic explanations eugenics
and so I think that's the
the uh darker reasons that we associate
it with Nazi Germany not the good reason
which is yeah we have to be careful and
learn from those those episodes in
history but it's also just the
manipulation of thought
um so yeah
it seems like an odd Paradox that occurs
especially with people from the super
Progressive left because on one hand
they want to have this sort of blank
slate approach to things which allows
for Pure meritocracy to come through but
also seem to be quite against
meritocratic systems as well because
implied in that is that the people that
don't succeed Were Somehow responsible
for their own failure but the solution
to that is well let's fold in the
heritability question Let's Fold in
behavioral genetics into this which
doesn't give everybody the same starting
point like by Design but that is so off
the table that it ends up being this
pretzel shaped loop-de-loop in a
desperate attempt to kind of zero out of
square the circle of this conversation
that is exactly right and it's
fascinating because the early
eugenicists after Galton and I mean
especially in England and the United
States were progressives
um because why because they thought
science could help us Advance our
species obviously it can right vaccines
contraception there of course downsides
to that that you've discussed on your
show but you know contraception at least
in principle you know women can now
control the reproductive choices and
decide when and whether to go to work
and that sort of thing and similarly
well the left thought we can control the
traits of our children so this does show
you because the early eugenesis were
progressives there's no doubt about that
it does show you there's nothing
inherent to the left that attaches them
to the blank slate but there is this
tradition going back to Marx and the
French Revolution and Rousseau and
especially now with the woke left
whereby they've put all their cards on
the blank slate this this doctrine that
any disparities we see for us are the
product of Oppression unjust
discrimination
deprivation in the household or bad
schools or something
and by doing that they're they're
actually hamstringing themselves because
as this technology and we can talk about
the technology now but as the technology
that's going to allow us to shape the
traits of our children
um is more and more developed and
available especially using in vitro
fertilization and embryo selection and
so on they're going to face an
increasing cognitive dissonance whereby
on the one hand they're going to have
every incentive to use this I mean
everyone recognizes heredity powerfully
shapes the traits of our kids but on the
other hand their official public
position is going to be to denounce it
because it's going to blow up their
entire world view
once you have a price on the false
belief in the blank slate once you have
to pay a price for example foregoing the
use of technologies that might improve
the welfare of your children
what you publicly say and privately
believe I think will become more and
more different until the blank slate is
blown up and far leftists are going to
have to just publicly endorse eventually
uh the reality of heredity
that's fascinating what's the difference
then between Eugenics and genetic
enhancement and embryo selection
yeah good question I think there is no
difference
um I think it's pretty clear that
genetic enhancement is a youthful
euphemism for eugenics
and some euphemisms are useful I mean
the truth is you know it can disarm
people when you say you're defending
Eugenics um I've certainly done that to
people you're our mutual friend Diana
Fleischmann likes to get under people's
skin by using the word eugenics
um so yeah some bioethicists and others
have used the term genetic enhancement
instead and you know you might say on
the one hand that that's kind of nice
because it doesn't have these emotional
associations with it on the other hand
it's the same thing and so the idea is
look
when we're talking about Eugenics or
genetic enhancement we're talking about
um paying attention to the genetic
traits of our kids whether we're
intentionally altering them or actually
intentionally refraining from altering
them for example
um you know crispr cast 9 can
technically be used now to edit the
genes of an embryo but there's so many
off-target mutations that would be
incredibly dangerous for you to try to
do that right now and I would say that
the decision to refrain from doing that
is itself a form of either Eugenics or
genetic enhancement you're using your
knowledge of heredity and how the
technology Works to shape the genetic
endowment of your kids
so in principle genetic enhancement is a
euphemism it's supposed to disarm your
opponent so that you don't think about
some of the downsides of eugenics but
the reality is we've always made these
distinctions in philosophy and in other
adjacent disciplines between voluntary
Eugenics and coercive eugenics between
Eugenics or genetic enhancement if you
want to call it that that is aimed at
improving the welfare of your child or
improving the welfare of all children
right
so again I'm not I'm not big on
definitions it's clear why we've chosen
this other definition and we we tend to
use genetic enhancement
but as you've probably seen from
reactions to the work I've written and
Diana Fleischman as well what they're
going to do if you use genetic
enhancement is just call you eugenicist
anyway so at that point why not just say
okay call me what you want what's really
important is like what are the policy
implications of this what are the
responsibilities that scientists and
parents have to use this technology for
the benefit of their kids and for
humankind
rather than misuse it in the form of
mass sterilizations and murder which
happened in Nazi Germany
I mean any time that I've ever had a
conversation about behavioral genetics
the people that didn't watch the entire
episode have a problem and call it
Eugenics I'm like you you're you're
pointing your finger at
Robert Plowman like the
was he the fourth or the ninth most
cited psychologist of the 1900s the
entire Century right and he's in the top
10 most cited psychologists like the
most Stellar research career you know
tens of thousands of twin pairs that
he's done with his research in the UK
and then uh
all over the world in Sweden and Japan I
mean yeah we have overwhelming evidence
yeah and then Stuart Richie comes up
Stuart Richie comes on to have another
discussion about behavioral genetics and
it's like there is um understandably I
suppose sensitivity around anything that
could slippery slope its way down to
forced sterilization of particular
groups of people and it is a little bit
of a shame looking back that the first
widespread adoption of eugenics on mass
was done by a group that used it for
such malign purposes that there is now
this quite arduous game that you need to
play in an attempt to talk about okay
well how can we maybe limit some really
bad genetic traits that occur within
people like everybody's already doing it
through the way that they choose their
mates in any case visually like what the
[__] do you think you're actually
attracted to when you choose the partner
uh but so why should anybody be in
support of genetic enhancement
good yeah and actually let me back up
and answer the final part of your
previous question first and then give
Arguments for enhancement you you
mentioned that sync between Eugenics
genetic enhancement which I said are
just kind of euphemisms and then embryo
selection so let me say something really
quickly about what's on the table right
now so of course we've always had mate
selection
and even going all the way back to Plato
and Aristotle they thought explicitly
about the biological basis of society
they actually thought the main virtue of
a political Society is to create a kind
of biomass that in turn produces a
certain kind of culture and Sparta it
was a fighting culture in Athens it was
a bit wiser for some period of time but
even they understood that like biology
shapes culture and vice versa it made a
comeback again and got its official name
Eugenics because of Darwin and Galt and
all of this and then fast forward a
century and a half and like why are we
talking about it all of a sudden now
partly it's because of behavioral
genetics we now really understand how
heritable certain traits are it's partly
because of computational genetics we're
now seeing like how the actual genes
work to produce those traits
but it's also because of Technology like
in vitro fertilization
the science of genome-wide Association
studies and what's called polygenic risk
scores so let me kind of develop each of
those
so since the 70s in in the US and
England and now the whole world we've
had this process of in vitro
fertilization at first it was just for
infertile or gay couples where you could
artificially stimulate the production of
eggs for women
and then you know you artificially
inseminate those eggs and then you have
a choice like which which embryo am I
going to implant
and it's fairly obvious if you're only
going to implant one or if that one
fails maybe a second one out of let's
say 10 or 20 you're not going to do it
at random I mean you could do it at
random but that seems insane in the same
way it's insane to choose a mate at
random right let's just throw the dice
and you know whoever it lands on the
nearest girl to me I'm gonna pick her to
marry me nobody does that
and so what you have in the 70s is you
can test for aneuploidy you can test for
Down syndrome these sorts of things Tay
sacks these really simple disorders that
are caused by a single gene or a set of
small small set of genes and obviously
you're going to not select that one and
then you'll select one of the other ones
but what's happened in the last say 20
30 years is well 10 years really we have
these genome-wide Association studies
from the UK biobank from the Japan
biobank they're about 10 or 12 of these
around the world where you take millions
of people and you genetically sequence
them and then what you can do is see
which ones develop let's say type 1
diabetes uh breast cancer which ones
tend to have more educational attainment
or even just score higher on IQ tests
which ones are taller and after enough
samples what you can do is just
associate these hundreds or thousands of
tiny genetic variants with traits and
then with some probability what you can
do
is for example now with IVF
sequence each of the embryos and it's
it's really not dangerous at all you
just take a tiny clip of that embryo
and run it through a kind of well
through a sequencer through an algorithm
and you develop what's called a
polygenic risk score and the idea is
most of the traits we care about
intelligence most forms of cancer it's
not caused by a single Gene disorder
it's caused by hundreds or thousands of
variants and what you can do then or now
is assign scores to different embryos
and now what people can do is say not
only do I not want the embryo with Tay
Sachs I also don't want the embryo
that's at extreme risk of of heart
disease or schizophrenia or and this is
now possible I know people are capable
of doing it intelligence so what you can
now do is assign a study polygenic risk
scores to those embryos and select the
one in accordance with whatever it is
that you want so couples are going to
select probably some more for health
then intelligence some maybe care more
about intelligence eventually it's going
to be personality and even political
orientation which are to some degree
heritable and that's really why all of
this is making a comeback now so tying
together Eugenics genetic enhancement
and embryo selection it's really the the
viability of doing embryo selection in a
more fine-grained way than ever before
that's kind of bringing back the debate
on on Eugenics and genetic enhancement
with this technology on the table
does it make it immoral as a parent who
is aware of it to not use it on your
child
I think so but that's a pretty
controversial view
um actually let me let me qualify that
um in large parts of the world most
people won't have enough money to go
through IVF for example so is it immoral
to do what you can't do no in philosophy
we have this famous saying Autumn Plies
can and if you can't do it then there's
no obligation for you to do it
but I would say the the more you
understand the technology and can afford
it
the stronger your obligation is
potentially to use it
and that's kind of hedging hedging my
claim but I think that's that's right it
should be hedged I still think for
example that the best thing that you can
do for your kids is choose the right
mate partly just because of the
environmental conditions you're going to
raise them in but also because let's
face it if IQ is heritable by about 80
percent by adulthood if lots of
personality traits are 50 heritable you
know I'm not an IQ maximizer but I want
my kid to be conscientious I want them
to have friends and to be able to
interact in socially productive ways and
frankly just like make the world a
better place you know and if you want
those kinds of traits the best thing you
can do is select a meet and then after
that
you know the cheaper the technology the
more powerful it is if you can subtly
influence those traits so that they're a
little bit nicer a little smarter a
little a little more likely to succeed
in life I think you should do it I think
that's fairly obvious
but I will say this I think the reason
that people
are hesitant to make claims like that is
first of all there are infertile people
and you don't want to make them feel bad
right so it's sort of like there's this
implicit message that if you say oh you
know you should have like a lot of kids
you know and you should really care
about the traits they have and some
people can't or some people let's say
are at the well let's just put it mildly
on the left side of the bell curve of IQ
or health or whatever saying you should
have genius kids when it's like not
really possible is is a bit of a slap in
the face to them so I do think there are
strong obligations here but I understand
why people are hesitant to acknowledge
it
is there something particularly
different
about
selecting from an existing combination
of your genetic material and your
partner's genetic material
and
somehow editing or creating genes
themselves within the existing pair so
with one of these situations you're
selecting from raw materials that you
provide and in the other one when the
technology perhaps advances further you
may be able to go in and edit and change
genes already is there something morally
different about those two do you think
I think the moral difference would only
stem from
the empirical realities so for example
like right now crispr has this problem I
should say crispr is the gene editing
system that we learned from bacteria
bacteria have been fighting phage
viruses that invade them for billions of
years so they've co-evolved right
um what crispr evolved as in bacteria is
a way of sequencing and disabling
various genes and viruses that attack
them so crispr actually use it it works
quite well we learn to use this from
bacteria the problem is if you were to
crisp or an embryo right now and you
wanted to change hundreds or thousands
of variants because that's what actually
produces complex traits there would be a
lot of a lot of mutations that you would
inadvertently produce but now let's say
that you take that away right well that
changes the moral calculus because like
if you knew for sure for certain right
and this is purely hypothetical you knew
there would be zero Downstream mutations
and the only thing there would be is
like decreased risk of heart disease
well of course you know you should use
it and you should you'd have a strong
obligation to use it even if even if you
and your partner didn't have the raw
genetic material to create the reduced
risk of heart disease that's right
that's right and and look we already say
this like you know at the extremes
governments take children away from
their parents when they refuse to feed
them enough when they basically create
an environment that ensures that they're
not going to develop properly and so we
do make moral claims about what parents
owe to their children like adequate
nutrition and exercise and like you know
put them in school don't just like keep
them home and don't teach them anything
and the same thing is going to happen
for genetics to the extent that our
knowledge improves the problem right now
is like yeah you wouldn't use crispr but
it's really more for you know scientific
reasons that lead you to that moral
conclusion so yeah I actually don't
think that there are intrinsic moral
reasons not to use it here's another an
another point though that's worth making
there's actually a really good
scientific objection to using crispr
right now on complex rates and that is
the plyotropy objection plyotropy occurs
when one genetic variant or a set of
variants produces multiple phenotypic
consequences so there's like one simple
example that's often used and that is
there's a genetic variant in East Asians
that causes both dry earwax and low body
odor odor right and it's like why
[__] you know you can give God knows
what evolutionary reasons or
explanations for that but
it's true it just you know so one of
them is either neutral or or maybe
they're both positive but like it's kind
of trivial
there's probably lots and lots of
plyotropy throughout nature and until
you actually understand what genes do
and we actually are a fair way from
understanding the total effects of all
genes one problem is by tinkering with
one gene you could inadvertently select
in favor of a healthy trait and against
um another trait where that trade is
actually even more healthy right so you
end up with like a net cost by [__]
around with the genome before you
actually know what every Gene does
now there's a reply to that and and one
of the interesting replies is that even
before we know what every variant does
it turns out there's something called
positive plyotropy and
um genomic prediction a company that
already does this what they do is
they've created an overall health index
such that it turns out when you select
against a set of variants that cause one
disease it's also more likely to reduce
a whole Suite of other diseases
and that's partly because again there
are genes or sets of genes that
basically are just bad for you
especially some of the more recent de
novo mutations everyone throughout their
lifetime acquires new mutations like
think of the freckles on your your skin
you know and and other kinds of defects
that we get that's visible
and we pass along those defects that was
one reason that Francis Galton and
Charles Darwin worried about developed
societies like England he said basically
it's inevitable that we're going to
accumulate more and more deleterious
mutations because our medical system and
our welfare programs basically ensure
that everyone survives and can reproduce
whereas when you have more ancestral
environments you get purifying selection
when there's a set of de novo mutations
that produce health risks Etc they're
likely to be selected out they're like
because the eye
Etc the technology and the social safety
net that you're given has raised the
minimum level of Health that somebody
can sorry yeah lowered the minimum level
of Health that somebody can survive at a
person that previously would have
existed for five years or ten years now
lives until they're 70 or 80 because all
of the support that they're given which
the side effect of that would be a
weakening of your immune system and if
you have those sorts of genes being
reproduced back into the gene pool that
then makes Downstream from that a quote
unquote
weaker Society yeah although I wouldn't
quite put it that way because what what
what the key is is that you're more
likely to live through your reproductive
age so it's not that you live longer
it's that you don't die when you're 20.
when you do something stupid or you know
you can you know famously you can just
get bifocals if you can't see very well
right which is good you know and Darwin
and Galton were quite happy I mean they
said look we're ambivalent about this
and we support a lot of the social
safety nets there are we certainly don't
think like we should abandon modern
medicine or antibiotics or something but
the net effect of that has to be just
the logic of it has to be that we're
accumulating deleterious mutations such
that essentially since we don't have
purifying selection anymore we're going
to build these up now John Toby The
evolutionary psychologist wrote a really
cool essay some years ago it's it's only
two pages long so all of your viewers
can can read it quickly and it's called
the race between germ line Gene editing
and genetic meltdown and it plays on
exactly this logic like
we are in this weird race whereby the
Richer we are the more inevitably
um deleterious mutations will get and
that will lead to a kind of slow genetic
meltdown unless we have ways of editing
those out or using embryo selection to
select them out
so this is like this is just part of
being human like we we get these massive
boosts and it's it's kind of like on the
cultural level like poor societies can't
afford to go woke they can't afford
insane beliefs like men and women have
the same capacities this is why you know
you show these videos of of some you
know like Leah Thomas or whatever the
transgender swimmer at Penn where I used
to teach to an African tribe and they're
just confused it's just really confusing
to them
and in the same way that when it's only
when you get really rich like wealthy as
a culture that you can afford to believe
things that are actually at odds with
reality itself
so too when you get rich you can
actually sort of impoverish at the
genetic level the individual and the
group unless there's some way of
altering those genes so yeah going into
a conversation I had a little while ago
with David Goggins about the equivalent
of the Overton window but for discomfort
so you could imagine that in the
um the maximum amount of Human
Experience you could have would be from
zero to 100 from Pain to pleasure and
what we have managed to do in the modern
world is constrain the guard rails I
would actually say on both sides I think
there's less dread but there's also less
ore as well and what that means is that
people are hyper sensitized as soon as
they step outside of that and this is
kind of the same but with regards to
genetics but what we've seen is a um
degree of security and comfort that has
come around through advanced Healthcare
through more Social Security and social
support and so on and so forth uh and
yeah we see this within our own lives
you know the person everybody has an
inclination even the most you know
Progressive Wilkie person has the
inclination of the silver spoon coddled
aristocratic family wanker and they also
understand that when they are faced with
adversity they are probably going to
struggle I think that one of the
concerns
would be from this again the slippery
slope down into the bad coercive form of
eugenics is well what about the freckled
Community are you saying that we need to
get rid of the freckled Community what
about them are you denying their
personhood and their identity how can
you how can you what about deafness what
about the deaf Community that's a
non-insignificant portion of people are
you saying that they're somehow uh Less
sub-optimal in a way that means that we
ought to get rid of them and all of
their future progeny what if we need to
select out from them and they can't have
children yep yeah it's great and that's
a common objection and you know
I used to not take it as seriously as I
do now but there is one way to take it
seriously and give a pretty good answer
to on the one hand I think it's clear
that if you're having children and you
can select let's say an embryo it's more
direct form of selection it's clear you
should select a kid that can hear right
and if they want to make themselves deaf
later they can do that it's a lot harder
to reverse it in the opposite direction
um it is true that in principle we could
imagine a world where people get more
callous toward minorities that have
various kinds of disabilities I mean
that did happen in the 1930s Hitler
actually deemed the old quote useless
eaters right they're they're consuming
more resources than they're producing
and so they're they're they're on the
chopping block right I mean it's
happened before
and in fact in human history it was
pretty common when resources are scarce
especially take you know Eskimos
famously if you get too old or too sick
they kind of push you out of the igloo
and onto the ice and it's it's your time
you know I mean it's not uncommon in
human history
might it make a comeback I think in
principle yes but it also shows that
genes aren't everything the power of
culture is real
and when you look at the last 40 years
in let's say the us or UK despite all
the social pathologies which we can talk
about
there's actually been a really
remarkable move toward moral inclusion
and so when you think about like
disability rights those have actually
increased in recent years not decreased
so it's perfectly compatible I think to
have a world in which you say look if
you're born unable to hear or you have
various disabilities we should have all
kinds of laws and Norms that protect you
but that's not inconsistent with saying
nevertheless like it's something to be
avoided like one of my best students
just to give an anecdote from Duke
University
um broke his neck he was about to enter
Duke uh 10 years ago on a diving
scholarship and an academic scholarship
he actually did enter on an academic
scholarship and he got into a diving
accident the summer before he entered
broke his neck he was in a wheelchair
the whole time remarkable kid he ended
up one of the best students I've ever
had got a road scholarship and went out
did his PhD at Oxford and now he's
working in politics here in the U.S but
I asked him actually when I was in a
controversy over this Eugenics stuff we
spent the summer together in Oxford I
was writing a book at the time and I was
like you know surely you know you would
want a cure for your current condition
he's like of course like you know like
on the one hand he's he's going around
arguing for disability rights and on the
other hand he doesn't want to be
disabled why would you want to be right
so I think a lot of these Scholars
um on the one hand they have a genuine
moral concern like we really should
protect both socially and legally the
disabled and have if anything even more
empathy for them
but that's not inconsistent with
selecting against disability and I think
a lot of
a lot of noise to the contrary is pure
virtue signaling right people want to
appear morally better than other people
and so they pretend like people who care
about health are somehow against the
disabled which is just [__]
I I don't think we should listen to them
I don't think we should take some of
their objections at face value because
they themselves don't believe it
just to round out the discussion about
genetic interventions is it your view
that they're not morally different from
environmental interventions from
stepping in to take the children away
from the parents that I'm feeding them
Etc
well they're different in a qualitative
sense I mean of course there's a
different mechanism right
um but they're not necessarily different
in their consequences like if you drink
alcohol
as a pregnant woman or you consume a lot
of sushi which has fish like tuna that
has high levels of mercury in it right
you actually have a serious risk of
impairing the brain development of your
kid or back in the 70s like when we had
lead and gasoline and paint a lot of
kids were born with like a 20 30 point
IQ deficit because at that crucial age
when your head is developing in the womb
in the first few years you know you're
likely to get this irreversible brain
damage
is that different than selecting in
favor of a low IQ kit at the genetic
level and my answer is no to the extent
that they're both bad for the kid
and they're both in some ways
irreversible so um you know
environmental deprivation or enhancement
can be just as reversible or
irreversible as genetic genetic ones can
be although genetics tend to be a little
more permanent
you might say okay one of the things
though about toying with or tinkering
with embryos is that
once you've decided to genetically edit
um you know some environmental
enhancements or alterations can be
undone not always like with the examples
I gave but you know genetics can't be
undone
but that's not true right if we have the
power to edit a gene in one generation
it's likely we're going to have even
more power in the Next Generation to
unedit if you know you think that
there's a better addition or subtraction
or whatever so I actually don't think in
principle it's any different than a lot
of environmental Innovations
or or sorry interventions but people
have a tendency to think it is because
genes are essential and environment is
somehow more flexible it's not always
true
is it a case of a naturalistic fallacy
as well
that just this is the way that it's
always been there's something that feels
the same way as uh the person who would
be maybe fine with taking antibiotics to
get rid of some infection that they have
wouldn't be okay with taking a vaccine
yeah
um I think I think that's true but also
when you look back at history there
there was resistance to not so much
antibiotics but certainly vaccines
um life extension like artificial
respirators there were church leaders
that were against these things right
because if it's your time you know God
God is taking you for a reason and so
you know the idea that you would use a
respirator to artificially extend life
is clearly immoral right now it's
immoral according to them if you if you
take it away right
um so a lot of this is
naturalistic fallacy because we've
always done it this way it must be good
as opposed to this new technology
um some of it is you know legitimate
skepticism toward new technologies I
mean look at the way the covid vaccine
was was pushed by Elites like my view
was always pretty moderate on this like
it looks like probably old people are
better off taking it young people
probably don't need it
um but but the reality as you saw right
is that there's this push like everyone
should have five boosters you know
fetuses should be given the covet shot I
mean just Total Insanity the
politicization of Science and the
reality is this is how this is how it
works with almost all new interventions
but let me mention actually briefly last
week
um there was a really interesting study
that was published in the journal
science and it was a comprehensive
survey of American adults and there were
thousands involved and they asked them
about their attitudes toward embryo
selection and specifically for cognitive
ability so they asked them like how
comfortable are you giving your kid like
SAT prep lessons right to give them an
advantage and and almost everyone said
yes amazing like 10 said that's immoral
I don't know why but whatever
um most people say yeah of course you
know classes environmental interventions
are okay
okay what about like genetic
interventions like using embryo
selection with polygenic scores to
select for cognitability and it turned
out the majority of Americans were
actually in favor of it and the numbers
go up as you go younger which is
reproductive age
and not only that but people were asked
separately like if a lot of people you
know and respect because people tend to
follow leaders right that's why they
look to Hollywood or professors or
journalists or politicians if those
people were using it would you be more
or less likely to use it and of course
almost everyone said more
and so I think what's going to happen
here is like a lot of other
technological innovation there's going
to be skepticism at first some of it's
sincere just like and legitimate right I
don't know what this is this seems a
little dangerous to okay this looks a
little less dangerous too well we have a
moral obligation to do it right and now
let's like subsidize it for everyone
um that's my view on what's going to
happen and I think that article in
science pretty clearly shows that's the
kind of pattern
what are the genetic enhancement
capabilities that we've got at the
moment
good
um we can minimize a variety of the
likelihood that a variety of mental and
physical diseases manifest themselves so
for example you can select against
schizophrenia
coronary artery disease type 1 diabetes
there's a lot of physical traits you
could if you wanted to select in favor
of height and cognitive ability although
the predictors can do that now you can
do that now yeah yeah I know people who
are definitely capable of doing it now
and I think within a few years it'll
probably be widely done
I think it's going to be China leading
the way they now have universally
subsidized IVF and once you have
subsidized IVF in vitro fertilization
it's just a really quick and easy step
to sequence those embryos and test them
for cognitive ability so I think it's
going to happen there more than anywhere
else first but
yeah just to give a hypothetical example
if you have 10 12 embryos what you're
going to get in terms of IQ gains
between the lowest and the highest
scoring embryo is roughly nine nine and
a half points it's a pretty pretty
standard deviation
yeah yeah close to a standard deviation
um that number is going to increase once
we get more knowledge of genetics but
there's there are upper limits to this
right because first of all there's only
so much genetic diversity that you
produce between two people
but there is something coming on the
horizon those of your your viewers who
are not happy with this technology are
going to be even less happy with what I
say now and that is that there's a new
technique called in vitrogumetogenesis
ivg which will allow you to take an
adult cell let's say a
skin cell a hair cell it could be blood
or bone
turn it into
an induced pluripotent stem cell
and that's the kind of cell that embryos
have right they're pluripotent stem
cells that's that's why the stem cell
debate was so important right if you
have a stem cell
um and it's undifferentiated you can
turn it into any kind of cell right
that's why you could like potentially
grow like a liver and a petri dish or
like a skin a batch of skin so that if
you're a burn victim you could actually
use one of your skin cells and produce a
whole patch of skin right
um but similarly if you can do that you
can produce an egg cell
and when you think about the
implications of that I could take
potentially a skin cell from a 60 year
old woman and turn it into a pluripotent
stem cell turn that into an egg cell
and if she had
um someone who could carry the child for
her and a sperm donor well your
grandmother could be having children and
her own children past menopause
but a bigger implication is that even if
a gene in an embryo were never edited
using crispr or anything else using this
technique we could have not 10 embryos
to select from but potentially five
hundred a thousand why not once it
scales and gets cheaper now couples are
going to have tremendous genetic
variation from which to select and my
vision of the future is I'm not saying I
even endorse this I think this is what
shall happen like it or not
is that you know in 50 years and 70
years I don't know what the time frame
is exactly we're already we're already
using IVF to select for polygenic traits
but there's probably going to be some
combination of of IVF using polygenic
risk scores plus ivg increasing the
number of embryos from which you choose
plus some light touching up with crispr
once you once you make it more accurate
and it produces fewer Downstream
mutations
probably what you'll want to do is yeah
again select from a large number of
embryos and then whatever residual
mutations are producing some elevated
risk of cancer disease maybe aging
um you'll want to you know crispr those
out a little bit and I think you're
going to be able to produce through that
process people who live longer who are
smarter who are healthier and happier
dude that's wild that's absolutely I
finished off a conversation are you
familiar with Richard rangam's work
goodness paradox
oh yes someone just gave me his book
actually yeah really good so tell me
really good tell me about it so we had
this really fascinating conversation he
is a primatologist Anthropologist uh
looked at the development the
co-evolution uh of human aggression over
time and his hypothesis is that we have
gone through self-domestication humans
have self-domesticated ourselves and if
you look at previous uh iterations of
homo you will find that they had longer
faces that they had heavier brow ridges
that they were less popified right and
his argument is that any individual
typically a male who was overly dominant
and tyrannical would have been killed by
the alpha Alliance as he calls this was
facilitated by a combination of uh
coalitional Warfare or hunting that was
whatever two million years old and then
about 300 400 000 years ago when we got
the ability to coordinate through
language you could have a very cleverly
put together the plan with you and your
Alpha Alliance buddies you take down
this Tyrant at the top and what that
means is that any man who crossed a
threshold of sufficient aggression would
be selected out of the the gene pool now
some of them would have reproduced on
average they're going to reproduce less
and what that means is that over time
you are deselecting for so we we
self-bred the same way as we
domesticated dogs and cows we did that
to ourselves now we get all the way
through this fantastic conversation
which is really really interesting and
then he gets toward the end or the very
very end and he says okay so what do you
think the future has in store you know
we're in this sort of Novel evolutionary
environment the selection pressures
previously that would have caused
particular tyrannies or tyrannical
individuals to have been stopped you
know maybe they're now in jail maybe
they're now doing something else but
they're not being killed he says well I
think actually rolling forward if you
look at what's going to be available
genetically we're just going to get rid
of the Y chromosome overall that we're
just going to be able to have women who
can self-reproduce uh who don't need
that and that males will will be
completely taken out of the species and
he made a case that that would be the
moral thing to do that almost all war
almost all aggression comes from the Y
chromosome he said it would be a a
socially civilizationally immoral thing
to not do to not get rid of men and I
was this was the final the final thing
that he said and I was like we've been
going for an hour and 25 minutes and I'm
like Richard I need to we'll run this
back and I'll we'll start from now and
then we'll go again uh in future but
that was the sort of the last thing uh
Echo that I was left with
um what what do you think about getting
rid of the Y chromosome from the future
of human civilization
um yeah it's I think you and I can agree
on this
um
yeah I mean you can get into some
territory that makes you really
controversial but I mean you already do
this on your show I guess I I think
they're masculine virtues that are
important and civilization building and
civilization preserving
I mean
also I mean okay it's true that women
have higher levels of affective empathy
they start wars less and so on they do
engage in massive psychological warfare
as you know there's a lot of intersex
Warfare It's just of a different kind
than than ours
um but yeah I think the masculine
virtues are real and important and um
civilization affirming so I don't like
the vision I think he's right I know
he's right and he's more of an expert
than I am but I've read a lot on Gene
culture co-evolution I think this is one
of the most interesting areas of the
last I don't know 30 years of research
Joseph Henrich at Harvard and you know
Jonathan height the political
psychologist we've all sort of started
to think in these terms Peter turchin
actually the opposite side of the
argument you just gave
you know he has a book uh called Ultra
Society how 10 000 years of war made us
the greatest Cooperators on Earth one of
the great things about war and and mass
conflict is that it incentivizes
coordination among existing groups and
cooperation so it produces a kind of
local altruism or you might call it
parochial altruism whereby it is true we
don't have Universal love for all humans
and Men especially don't have this women
tend to have a little bit more of that
Universal altruism on the other hand
this is a good thing because it allows
us to bond together with a tribe it this
this is what sports is obviously right
this is why men like sports more than
women do
um it allows us to identify a tribe to
set goals to achieve those goals in
meaningful ways it gives us a reason to
live in the morning to get up in the
morning right so I actually think that
he's right genes and cultures co-evolve
we've self-domesticated although that
was a kind of emergent order it was a
kind of smithian or darwinian invisible
hand process nobody planned that
obviously right if anything it was the
opposite people going to war or doing
things like killing the alpha male and
and violently killing them and enjoying
the process of just destroying him right
that actually made us more Cooperative
or or more docile in some ways but do we
want to get still more docile I don't
know about that I don't want to no and
think about it this way in retrospect if
you were to say is it moral or was it
moral to kill the most violent members
of your tribe that's that's Eugenics
that's coercive Eugenics absolutely
that's murder it's just straight up
murder and yes and yet Downstream from
that you can say okay we were able to
create a
um
genetic social cultural landscape which
is more optimal more peaceful more uh
coalitional more coordinated more
altruistic than it would have been had
we have allowed all of these tyrannical
males to have continued to exist and you
go okay so it was bad at the time but it
was good after the fact this to me just
it's not motivated reasoning but it's
kind of like availability bias it's like
look so you're living in the world that
you're in now so in retrospect the thing
that we did was the thing that was good
and it's just a very sort of difficult
messy scenario to get into another
element here to just
off the back of what you're saying to do
with the masculine virtues that we have
at the moment I think that especially in
a post-metu world what a lot of
cultural popular culture tried to do was
to sanitize some of the more toxic
elements of aggressive male Behavior
both sexually socially interpersonally
Etc but what ended up happening was it
sterilized all male behavior and I think
the only reason that we are able to see
that as anything approximating not
totally terrible is because we're in a
time of severe peace you know there are
there is no alien civilization which is
coming over the edge of the solar system
toward us but if that was to happen one
of the first things that I would suggest
is okay all pawn immediately gets
switched off all video games immediately
get switched off all social media except
for necessary communication gets
switched off because what you're going
to do is you'll be familiar with Diana
fleischman's uncanny vulva's theory that
you get this titrated dose of porn that
kind of satisfies men's reproductive
values which is why we haven't seen
young male syndrome and all of these
guys causing havoc and stuff
um
this is my male sedation hypothesis that
if we take away the sedatives the porn
the video games the social media you're
going to amp up that amount of
aggression now yeah absolutely if there
isn't anything for those men to direct
it out if it's not
um 18th century Portugal and you're
putting them all on Galleon ships to go
explore the new world because only the
eldest son is the person that gets into
a into a marriage then yeah they're
going to turn that inward they're going
to push over granny graffiti walls and
start pillaging but if you have an enemy
that you can point them to then it's
really useful so what you're saying now
is that the uh like socio-political
landscape that we are in has created a
world in which useless men are perhaps
slightly more optimal than dangerous men
but that's not necessarily always going
to be the case
yes and this was also this was
Nietzsche's worry in well thus spokes
erathustra where he coins the term
Superman and last man right who is the
last man well the last man he says first
of all values equality above all else
um and he values momentary Pleasures
above danger he basically is the the man
that has been emasculated and he says
behold the last man this is what we're
becoming in in peaceful Europe now
Europe wasn't that peaceful in the 20th
century all the time but actually it's
one of the most peaceful centuries in
human history despite the two world wars
and and Nietzsche was really worried
that when we remove all of these threats
and all of these cues that activate
precisely what you said we're just going
to become pathetic men we're gonna
become last men and he of course
advocated the Superman which was some
alternative alternative Vision the the
Ubermensch
um
there's another interesting aspect of
this which is we not only don't have
these kinds of social cues but we now
have relaxed sexual selection by women
so women have always been the choosers
of men right most women historically
leave surviving offspring and large
numbers of men either leave none or
leave very few compared to the kind of
dominant men the smartest men the most
whatever athletic men whatever the case
is
and what we have is a scenario now where
we not only value monogamy above all
else but in Western societies we have
these government social welfare programs
such that you know traditionally a woman
would need to to select for moral
virtues like How likely is this guy to
stick around help me raise my family my
children
help actually defend my tribe and my
family as a whole and defend me that's a
kind of moral virtue is he smart is he
going to be able to solve the kind of
Novel problems that inevitably arise
over time where there's novel threats
maybe we go to war at some point
um is he physically capable of Defending
me so they would select on all these
traits and now the government is
essentially the father and they can
basically just get pregnant by whoever
some you know muscly dude with no brains
and and the government is going to take
care of that person the government is
essentially going to subsidize child
care and so on now I understand their
arguments for this but this has to have
massive civilizational and genetic
consequences women don't have incentives
to select for the best man in the sense
of the most virtuous the smartest the
most creative because the government is
essentially solving the problems that a
male would have been tasked with solving
originally so that's just to add to this
idea that you know
cultures shape genetics they always have
whether it is advertent or inadvertent
and right now it's not like we can sort
of say like okay cool like history
produced what we are now let's just stay
with what we've got now well we're not
staying anywhere right culture is
already producing massive genetic
changes and the ability to either change
our culture or more deliberately change
our children through these genetic
Technologies these are going to be
available they're options on the table
and you can't just sort of plug your
ears and go no no I'm just going to sort
of stay away from all of it like the
decision to do nothing is a decision to
shape future humans in very specific
ways whether you like it or not
so what what are the main
characteristics that you think people
are going to want to enhance when the
technology is fully available there's no
Downstream risks
yeah
well a clue is just what you can do
surveys now but you know as economists
like to say actions reveal preferences
whatever you ask people look at what
they do not at what they say so
sometimes they'll tell the truth but you
know your average New York Times
columnist is a blank's latest right so
they're going to say oh intelligence I
don't even know what that means IQ tests
just measure the ability to take IQ
tests they're just nonsense
but in their private lives they're
obsessed with intelligence right the way
they select their grad students their
mate the way they brag about their kid
being at Princeton you know not that
state school you know Rutgers or
whatever right so these people are
obsessed with it so one thing is you
could ask people but you know they like
to lie for political reasons but watch
what people do how they select their
mates and and more specifically watch
how they act at the sperm or egg Bank
when for example they're a gay couple
or an infertile couple or they just
electively are are choosing sperm or
eggs because they didn't find a mate
that they that they like and here's what
they choose so here's what women choose
in sperm clinics
intelligence or signs of intelligence so
they ask about educational attainment
where did you go to school would you
study
um athletic ability Health they like it
when people were a member of a team a
sports team that shows that they're not
only healthy but Cooperative Etc
um and then they ask for things like
kindness which may be surprising to
people but it's true when women can
select
um
in in the IVF Market or in the sperm
Market as opposed to in The Mating
Market they more directly select exactly
what traits they want so you know women
May famously like date the [__] as
they call them right like I know he
treats me like [__] but God I'm just so
attracted to him nobody acts like that
in the sperm Clinic when they're
actually deliberately selecting children
instead of emotional they're much more
transactional in that kind of a way or
much more direct perhaps they are and
women are even though extroverted guys
do better on the dating Market women are
pretty pretty clear that well they'll
they're equally likely to choose
introverts as extroverts when they're
selecting let's say the father of their
children when it's like a sperm donor
but I think that sums up to like how are
people going to choose well take a look
at what they're already doing in those
markets and I think that probably is not
only good evidence that they'll do this
when it comes to like Gene editing and
embryo selection but it turns out it's
like really optimistic like some people
are they're afraid well what you're
going to choose is male Psychopaths
right why because well they're more
socially dominant and they're going to
make more money well first of all that's
not true Psychopaths mostly end up in
prison and despite what people say it's
not true that most CEOs are psychopaths
they may be more disproportionately
represented there than in other
occupations like family medicine or
something
but for the most part Psychopaths don't
live good lives and people know that and
they don't want to choose Psychopaths
they actually want to choose people who
are reasonably nice but nevertheless
retaliatory because they don't want them
to be taken advantage of in a world
where not everybody else is nice so I
think that's how they're going to choose
I think it's pretty clear
Ava any theoretical limits to increasing
IQ
I don't know of any but I do know that
there may be some really small risks on
the really high end of IQ so there have
been some claims that you know above a
certain threshold that some mental
disorders are more likely to be found
but those papers don't replicate well at
all and there aren't very many of them
so I don't think there's really much
evidence at all that there are downsides
to a high IQ
um there's like a really really small
correlation maybe 0.1 or 0.2 between
extremely high q and Asperger's
um but what that is is the really high
form high functioning form of autism
it's not low functioning autism where
the kid is totally dependent on the
parents for the rest of their lives it's
more like you know the nerdy Professor
who is always like classifying
everything you know they live perfectly
good lives maybe they're just Geeks or
whatever right so there is some risk of
that at the high end of IQ but it's not
well studied and the upside is extremely
high I mean the probability that you'll
earn a PhD or earn more than 200 000 a
year or or be successful in The Mating
Market these things actually go up and
up and up with IQ
and moreover what's that the men IQ and
female mating success isn't
fantastically well correlated
oh I see I see
um in other words like there may be
thresholds to how well you do well I
know the probability of divorce goes
down so I don't know about actually
finding a mate but keeping your mate is
more likely to be true after a certain
level yeah different explanations for
that so lower IQ people tend to get
divorced more for example
um is that a good also
you may have a higher IQ women may also
correlate with more disagreeability
perhaps which would perhaps make it more
difficult for them to get into a
relationship with a man who's looking
for a slightly more agreeable woman
interested yeah yeah I don't know the
evidence there but it sounds plausible
and um yeah so there may be some
downside risk and since women are
choosier than men as you know and higher
IQ women earn more money than men it may
be that there's the risk that there's
like no one left in the dating pool to
find if you're like you know a knockout
with a 150 IQ making a quarter of a
million a year like there's just no
eligible bachelors I I suppose that is
more of a risk for women than men yeah
correct that's what I've deemed a tall
girl problem so if you sit on top of
your own uh dominance or competence
hierarchy and you're looking to date up
and across you're you're stood on
Everest trying to find something higher
to to get up to okay so yeah
cognitive and intelligence enhancement
uh personality for instance what what
are the sort of things that people want
to do there conscientiousness presumably
industriousness
yeah clearly and um you know I think
when we get into personality traits
that's where it is just trade-offs all
the way down right so conscientiousness
tends to be a good thing there's no
doubt about that where you think about
you create plans and you follow them
right and that's more likely to get you
things like health wealth uh friends
because you remember their birthdays you
remember what they what they really like
and you give them the gift that oh wow I
can't believe you remembered that right
on Valentine's Day or on my birthday or
whatever so conscientious is really good
other traits are mixed bags but even
conscientiousness if you selected for
the most conscientious person you could
possibly select for it may be that on
both sides of the bell curve at the
extremes they end up producing
psychopathologies like obsessive
compulsive disorder or something like
that on the extreme of conscientiousness
and the downsides right if you're
selecting against it those are fairly
obvious right you might be really good
at like exploiting other people in the
moment but you don't really think enough
about the future or you know um thinking
about the needs of others and responding
appropriately
but then you take stuff like openness
right so take ocean right openness
conscientiousness extroversion
agreeableness and neuroticism
I think again there's trade-offs so like
when you go high on openness that
actually inadvertently selects in favor
of political liberalism
um is that good or bad I don't know
depends on the distribution of traits in
the society that we have and and what
you want you know um
you know so liberalism and that's a
poorly defined term because we now tend
to connect liberals which would have
included like Adam Smith and Friedrich
Hayek with also like the most extreme
progressives which I mean there's really
no overlap between them but in America
for whatever reason we just call anyone
on the left a liberal what I really mean
is high openness is going to correspond
with something like Classical liberalism
like thinking about people as
individuals being maximally open to new
experiences but again if you're really
open you're not only more likely to be
liberal in that sense the classical
liberal sense you're probably going to
be more subject to exploitation by
people who are not so open and who are
more tribal than you are and so you can
think about the downsides of even
openness which is a pretty good trait
right you're willing to learn from
others you're open to new experiences ah
[__] somebody just took advantage of
your openness and your your trustingness
so I think when it comes to these things
it's going to be trade-offs all the way
down it's going to be really interesting
because I don't know maybe introverts
will prefer introverts or if they're
extremely introverted and they actually
see that they're really shy for example
they'll probably want to select the
opposite
I don't know what do you think what do
you think people will select for what
would you select for if it was me
certainly conscientiousness but you you
don't want anything to probably be above
80 or below 20 right if you take
yourself into the 90th percentile of
anything there's probably going to be
some weird externalities that come from
that uh do you want introversion or
extraversion you go well I've it's so
everything's so idiosyncratic and the
openness thing oh well I've got
conscientiousness plus openness okay
well this me might mean that they're an
incredibly great hard-working artist
that is able to both see their craft and
be able to be sufficiently disciplined
to move it forward but what if they fall
in love with trying to be an accountant
and they can't focus on a spreadsheet
because they're constantly trying to
think about new ideas and new ways to do
it so it's very very difficult to do I
think that there's definitely some you
know base pairs or whatever that you
want to try and get together it's one of
the things I'm most fascinated by is
attractiveness about whether or not be
people would be able to select for
attractiveness you can think about
fishery and runaway where you know big
eyes or big boobs or a big bum or wide
shoulders or low muscle body fat or
whatever are things that um
assortatively or in terms of mate
selection people are already looking for
but when it comes to selecting your kids
I guess one slightly uncontroversial
thing that most people would look to
select for would be symmetry in the face
that's right and and some of the other
body proportions maybe yeah we all have
our own tastes there but they're kind of
within a a window right I mean you know
when you think of waist to hips ratios
there's kind of a golden ratio of I
guess it's 0.7 and again our mutual
friends Dana Fleischman Jeffrey Miller
people like this can tell you more about
it but
um still within that range like you said
different kinds of curves or height in
men or shoulder width some of which are
totally unnecessary maybe
counterproductive from the standpoint of
like I don't know being able to walk or
live in the world in a way that feels
good to you right that those are more
ways of attracting mates and so on even
chemistry as well right like people that
are over I think is it people that are
over six four tend to live less Long
than people that are under six foot yeah
and have more you know back problems and
things like that so I mean and this is
an interesting point too when you think
about height
um yeah it's clear that people want to
select on height more for men than women
if they have boys rather than girls they
want the boys to be tall those are
sexually selected traits and they
understand like that correlates with
even financial success perceived
Authority if you're in politics or
business right we've all seen the famous
like debates with politicians and you
know Trump even makes like the the tiny
hands argument for Marco Rubio like
people really do amazingly have these
associations if you have small thin
hands as a man like you're probably not
going to win a war or something right or
you're short that may or may not be true
but people have these associations
so yeah with with runaway selection I
guess the issue is you might be afraid
that some of these traits people select
on like height or body shape will go to
these extremes that will actually give
you disabilities but one obvious reply
to that is the one you just gave which
is there's a kind of self-equilibration
such that if there's a movement toward
those extremes and they actually have
those really bad side effects you're
gonna you're gonna select in the
opposite direction I think
um so in some cases you're actually
going to deliberately select against
those because you don't want the side
effects and in other cases like facial
symmetry everybody wants it and for good
reason why because it's an indication of
something like either
uh genetic fitness so you have a low
genetic mutation load low oxidative
stress or low parasite load and parasite
load is at least partly partly a
function of the environment but partly a
function of your immune system which is
mostly genetic right an Adaptive immune
system
so when you select interestingly in
favor of facial symmetry
and even to a lesser extent male height
because taller than average Men actually
are healthier I say this as an exactly
average size man at five nine there's
some evidence for that when you select
for some of those aesthetic traits
you're inadvertently selecting in favor
of Health people may not know that but
that's why that's why you find that
attractive and the opposite sex that's
that positive polygenic risk thing
again oh positive plyotropy yeah that's
right that's exactly right yeah and it's
it's an unconscious Force that's been
sculpted through sexual selection what
do you find attractive nobody finds
attractive massive asymmetry quite the
opposite like if your eyes or even the
slightest bit asymmetrical people
immediately see it and they're like
that's weird right I mean you're not
supposed to say that out loud but that's
the reaction they have and that's for
good reason we've been honed through
sexual and natural selection forever
I mean that's the that's what we sort of
mentioned toward the start and I really
want to try and Hammer it home that yeah
every single person
that has ever had sex or chosen a
partner is already genetically selecting
your kids even if they were a condom and
you were on the pill
you are already doing this there are
genetic markers that you can see in your
partner I remember once uh I think
Jeffrey told me that he he rolled over
in bed and looked at Diana and said
you're such a lovely bundle of Fitness
signals
um beautiful yeah which is the I imagine
one of them
yeah exactly so tell me more about my
polygenic risk scores yeah but
the point being that why is it that men
want waist to hip ratio why is it that
women want High shoulder to waste ratio
for men what is it with facial symmetry
what is it with good skin not skin
that's covered in Legions what is it
with the full head of healthy looking
hair what is it with good straight teeth
what is it with not bad breath not bad
body odor you know pick whatever it is
that you find attractive unless it's a
very particular kind of quirk
yeah almost all of the things that you
pick are already these kinds of genetic
markers like humor in men well humor is
not that far away from intelligence
right the ability to be funny is quite
tightly tied to social intelligence as
well as straight up IQ because in order
to be funny you need to be quick so okay
like what is it that makes being
humorous attractive well it's because
that person has genes that if you had a
child with them would make funny
children so the sexy son or sexy
daughter hypothesis you know works again
so I I think it can get all the little
uh sterile sometimes when talking about
the the individual traits and we're
selecting them and you know it can it
can sound sound a little
um detached from the humanity of it all
but we're doing this in a Ruffian way in
any case we're doing this in an analog
action already it's just that we're now
moving into a slightly more digital
slightly more targeted world
that's a really good way to put it
um and in fact one book about the future
of this is by Craig Venter who was the
first to sequence the human genome in
the year 2000 and he does a lot of
what's called synthetic biology now but
his book is called life at the speed of
light and what he meant with the light
metaphors not just that we're moving
faster and faster through cultural
Evolution scientific advancement but
we're now into the age of digital
biology and he means that both
metaphorically and literally before we
understood in an analog way like Mendel
understood there have to be little units
of inheritance somehow like traits are
being transmitted and now what we can do
is just tell you exactly which variants
are producing which traits
um we were already doing it before it's
just a more precise way of doing it
I I want to say something though about
what you just said it I love it I mean
with the with the humor point you know
I've always thought about this as a way
of creatively solving problems like you
said it's a form of social intelligence
it's a form of inference it's playing on
other people's
expectations and then leading them down
like a left curve and so what you're
doing is you're showing through this
really interesting display that you
understand how other people think and
can manipulate it not in a bad way
um but you can relate to them so well
that you know exactly what they're going
to anticipate and then the conclusion of
the joke almost always ends up being
something very different than they were
thinking and that's what it's a kind of
a kind of trustworthy empathy in a way
yes exactly it's cognitive empathy it's
exactly what
um well Psychopaths have it to some
degree they have this Machiavellian
empathy but autistic severely autistic
kids don't they don't have a good theory
of mind and so what you're doing with
jokes is showing intelligence showing a
kind of social intelligence and then
cognitive empathy but I wanted to say
one other thing that you picked up on
that was fascinating that I've never
thought of before
you said for a lot of traits you would
want to like choose between I don't know
the 20th and 80th percentile you
wouldn't want to go too far out and then
you said 90th for something else
Maybe conscientiousness
and one thing that I've seen on this
evidence of the way that women choose
sperm donors is they actually do choose
intelligence up to about the 90th or
95th degree or percentile and then their
desire for it actually goes down a
little bit it flattens off and goes down
and I always wonder whether these
heuristics we have like are some
darwinian wisdom like there really is
something to this it gets dangerous
above a certain level or whether it's
just a heuristic we've developed that is
a kind of stereotype that's [__]
that's false I don't know but it's it's
really interesting that you have this
intuitive sense and the data shows that
women completely agree with that they
actually start getting scared on the
extremes I just figured that anything
where you tune it up toward absolutes is
going to end up having some pretty
strange Downstream consequences I mean
Cal Newport talks about this with the
fact that email shouldn't be free emails
should cost five cents to send because
it would change the entire landscape but
when you drive the price or the cost of
anything down to zero
you end up with very odd externalities
it's the same way as if you tried to
eradicate absolutely all in group or
outgroup biases from the world if you
wanted to get rid of all of them you end
up with some super bizarre externalities
if you want to drive them down to let's
say 10 percent
then you you probably end up with way
fewer
that's a great analogy and of course on
a maybe this is controversial maybe not
but on a social level we can see this so
take like Sweden over the last 30 years
they've gone through these waves where
they accept refugees and whatever your
opinion on that doesn't matter much but
you know some of the refugees they were
taking were committing a
disproportionate amount of crime and so
on and you know their response was okay
then we'll just stop collecting crime
statistics so we don't know who's
committing the crime and and here's what
I was getting out with with this point
there's a kind of pathological altruism
where you actually not only don't have
extreme in-group preference right like
racism and so on but you actively have
no in-group preference
to the point where you actually allow
yourself to just be subjugated by
outside forces so there was a judge in
Sweden some years ago who upon hearing
that one of these refugees had raped a
bunch of women
um there was a there was he was a
refugee claimant and initially there was
a ruling like he should be sent back to
Somalia I think it was and the judge
said well no if we send him back to
Somalia that's an even more dangerous
place than Sweden and so we're going to
keep them here in Sweden because like we
really want to protect this guy you know
it's not his fault that he's a rapist
and like break all of your rapists here
exactly talk about pathological altruism
I mean that's it that's a case where
it's like look we all understand
in-group preference can be bad right
there's no doubt about that a lot of
historic wars were a kind of
pathological form of in-group preference
but is the opposite really so great and
you know you talked about you know this
previous guest and I that sounds like a
fantastic conversation but I think you
and I have the same sense of resistance
toward that final point he made right if
we could only all become women it would
be great and it's like no like how much
of Life how much of the greatness of
life is driven by competition and
in-group preference actually a lot of it
is team sports would disappear without
that that high that you get when you're
you know I like to go to the boxing gym
I like to do pickup Sports surfing we
don't really get this because it's more
individualistic but I love team sports
even though I'm better at the individual
ones like surfing I'm not that good at
basketball but I love it because of that
high you get where you bond with your
team and you have that almost it's not
hatred but yeah kind of disrespect for
the out group and and it's it's fun it
leads you to achieve great things and
that's true throughout life right your
team is like motivated to distinguish
themselves and what would happen if we
got rid of that I think we'd be terrible
what can you foresee as some of the
potentially negative societal impacts
of this technology let's say that it is
well actually first off what is the kind
of timeline
that we're looking at to be able to get
us to an appreciable amount of
enhancement slash selection capacity for
the traits that we've spoken about and
other ones like morality and religiosity
and dominance and blah blah and then
Downstream from that what are the
societal concerns and impacts really
good question so
um predictions are always you know
things that we regret in retrospect most
people even when you get them right it's
probably because we were partly lucky
like I was like you know my friends who
you know predicted Trump was going to
win it was like okay it's not that hard
you know it's not like you know it was
just completely impossible that you
would win like even even the pundits
thought it was like a 20 chance I mean
so some predictions come out right by
chance let me give you like a rough a
rough prediction on where we're going
polygenic risk scores for embryo
selection are already here they're
getting more powerful every year we can
already do it from for intelligence
um I think we'll hit the limits of those
though again until we get more genetic
diversity through things like in vitro
gametogenesis or if people wanted to to
opt for like sperm and egg donation
rather than husbands and wives I don't
think that's necessarily the best
Society but like some people will do
that I know a lot of people from college
women who hit their 40s and they just
didn't find the right guy and they're
doing that they're just they're
selecting a sperm and then they're going
to on top of it select embryos so that's
already happening it's going to get more
and more powerful for like the next 10
years in vitrogametogenesis like powers
that up even more
my view is you know I'm not an expert on
Gene editing but I've talked to some
experts in particular I'm thinking of
one guy I guess I won't name him at the
broad Institute I guess this can be
controversial so I won't name him but
he's actually pretty skeptical that Gene
editing
will happen for even 50 years like on a
mass scale if ever so for reasons I
don't fully understand he thinks this
problem of Downstream mutations is a big
one and there may be no way to fully
correct that even if that's true I still
think we're going to manipulate
individual genes because the risks are
lower if it's just like this one gene
the one that causes Tay Sachs for
example
but if it turns out there's always some
probability of these Downstream errors
when you're manipulating highly
polygenic traits it may be that I don't
know Gene editing is 20 or 30 years away
or even 100 or I it's really hard to
know
um so I think that the main game in town
for now is embryo selection and again
going back make selection
but I will say something about the
inequality issue I think that's an
important one I do think inequality is
just like inequalities of wealth above a
certain level can lead to
a lack of social cohesion for obvious
reasons right it's kind of like a winner
take all system like I don't think
polygamy is such a bad thing in terms of
like the genetic effects of it right if
if the smartest or strongest or whatever
the traits are that you want are having
a disproportionate share of the children
like that's actually good for future
Generations on the other hand it leads
to massive social instability right this
is one one reason monogamy evolved is to
kind of control the you know the the
alpha males and to lead to more
stability
um but yeah we can get these like
genetic inequalities either through
again hypergamy or polygamy but you can
also get them through assorted of mating
and we're already doing it even before
you have Gene editing or embryo
selection which has just come online
what we've had is increased genetic
inequality in the last century why would
we have that well women's education
so for the first time like women are
getting actually more education than men
and because of their choosiness and
their preferences
um what's happening is like a female
doctor will just marry a male surgeon or
a really successful male lawyer and a
janitor will marry well another janitor
or someone who works at Walmart or
whatever and that's not casting shade on
someone who works at Walmart I mean
that's that's a job and those people
deserve you know to be treated with
respect and dignity and everything else
I mean I'm not sort of making judgments
about it but if you do the genetic math
here these traits are heritable and the
more assorted of mating we have and
intelligence is the number one trait
along which People assertively Mate
along with height and some some other
aesthetic traits
we're already getting increasing genetic
inequalities in the west without any of
this technology what will the technology
do it'll accelerate those inequalities
except we have the ability to actually
enable people who are poor through
subsidies for IVF subsidies for genetic
counseling and so on to Gap those
genetic inequalities I think there's
going to be a time where these new these
new procedures especially embryo
selection for some of these complex
traits they're going to be really
expensive but like cell phones like cars
like plane trips right it used to be a
luxury for the rich what the rich are
going to do is drive the the price down
and the quality up and so there's going
to be this temporary period maybe 20
years where we get even more genetic
inequalities through assorted of mating
and the use of these Technologies but
then we quickly get pressure
to ramp up the ability to use these in
an even more efficient way by this the
so-called genetic poor and I don't mean
that again is as like an insult I just
mean not everyone has like these natural
abilities you know I don't have the
natural height that you have or whatever
so I'm genetically poor with respect to
height
will my grandchildren have the ability
to select right yes like way more than I
can and so I think they'll the
grandchildren will will Bridge these
genetic gaps that was something that I'd
never really learned about before I was
listening to you and it's this the rich
pay
over the odds for new technologies when
they first come online that creates a
market companies then move into the
market market pressures then occur then
it's the slightly less rich people the
slightly less rich people the slightly
less rich people and downstream from
that you have what in the beginning
created potentially massive advantage or
inequality toward the people at the top
actually then trickling down to create
the opportunity for everybody to benefit
from these that is that a common Dynamic
it was the first time that I'd ever
heard of it when you started speaking
about it when I was listening to you
basically all of technological
innovation is like that think of the
people who are using boxy cellular
phones in their Porsches in the 1990s
the phone did nothing other than give
you the ability to have barely have a
conversation with other rich people in
your Porsche right it wasn't now we've
got like these incredibly powerful
computers in in our pockets and poor
African farmers are using these for like
you know they've got Bitcoin wallets or
whatever right so when the government
tries to seize their property they
actually have virtual property and it's
on you know this electronic medium which
like even you and I wouldn't have been
able to afford 20 years ago right or
wouldn't be able to do much the same
goes for the use of yeah again think of
who's flying now well it's one reason
like flights are so miserable now right
like they're packing everyone under
these cheap flights but you know for the
poor that's like a really big benefit
like the idea that they could fly to
another continent they couldn't afford a
[__] boat to another continent that
you know that would take six weeks just
a hundred years ago the average person a
hundred years ago would have never heard
music in their lives you can't afford a
piano you can't afford a ticket to like
the palace where the symphony is and now
you can afford like a five dollar shitty
radio that you just turn on and you get
like Symphonies from around the world in
different musical styles why because
rich people subsidize the the creation
and the dispersion of that technology
I'll take this even farther you know one
of the things that bothers me about
climate reparations this idea that you
know Britain and the US owe the world
huge amounts of money because they
polluted the environment well first of
all they're not the main polluters
anymore right it's obviously China India
and eventually Africa but secondly that
pollution came as a byproduct of
inventing everything that matters the
airplane antibiotics all of modern
medicine vaccines the internal
combustion engine nuke clear power
everything that makes your life go well
the kind of walls that I have I don't
even know what they're made of because
we have this division of labor that
makes them so much better and so much
cheaper than the mud Huts that we would
otherwise be living in like if anything
climate reparation should be going
toward Britain's and toward you know
swedes and Japanese who invented
practically everything in the world that
matters but instead we're flogging
ourselves going oh but there was some
pollution produced as a byproduct yeah
no [__] everything has you know some
cost but like the entire world a hundred
years from now is going to be
fantastically wealthy because of these
products we innovated over the last 200
years especially since the British
essentially created the Industrial
Revolution and made the world rich I
think we can pay for a little bit of
pollution
um you know as a side effect of that so
anyway to tie that together all new
technology is a toy for the rich until
it's not and the technology gets better
and cheaper precisely because of the
rich take the risks to subsidize it for
everyone else yeah they're not doing it
altruistically but the total effect and
this is this is a smithian point right
this is what Adam Smith meant by the
Invisible Hand he said look
in a market society and he's looking
around London at the time
we get this division of labor so the the
butcher the Brewer and the baker they're
just trying to get a good deal like I'm
not making bread for you because I like
you I might like you but like I'm just
trying to sell a bunch of bread you're
trying to sell beer and somebody else is
a butcher but the cumulative effect of
this process of trade and and that's
really what we're talking about right
the development of technology and these
industrialized societies is that it's as
if an invisible hand as if the the hand
of God was redistributing Resources by
pulling them out of the ground turning
them into cool [__] and giving them away
to everyone it's as if there's this
benevolent invisible hand you know
creating all of this for everyone and
it's really these climate reparations
people and these people who think oh you
know the rich they owe so much to the
poor because look at them they have all
this you know these these fancy cars or
like genetic technology okay maybe maybe
there's an argument to tax them to
redistribute a bit yeah but you know the
reality is they're actually subsidizing
almost everything that matters for
everybody else
is there something particularly unique
about genetic enhancement given that the
assortative advantages between couples
who have both wealth and the existing
genetic material will then have kids who
are x times percent smarter better
prepared plus they'll have the resources
plus their prepared will give them the
opportunity to accumulate more resources
which will allow them to accrue more and
more is there a concern that you end up
with a forking in society if the Haves
and the have-nots and that even though
this may cause a trickle-down of Cheaper
IVF with selection to be available for
poor people that a problem will be there
is a runaway effect which has meant the
the
um it's impossible to catch up to the
first movers within this particular
domain good yeah I mean that's that's of
course the theoretical possibility and
um
you know I think it's an interesting
question we'll go through the
ramifications but the obvious response
over fears like that are to ban the
technology and one thing I've written
about you know because I sort of I think
like an economist I studied both
philosophy and economics in the book
that I wrote on this topic I took very
seriously the problem of black markets
because the idea is look when there is
something for which demand is inelastic
is really strong even when price is high
what you get by outlawing it is not
um to prevent inequalities but to
exacerbate them because it's only the
richest and the most well connected who
can afford to use the technology anyway
they travel to another country to do it
maybe Mexico maybe Singapore whatever it
is and so
I think the more obvious response to it
is not to ban it I mean yeah certain
versions of the technology might be
banned sure or regulated but rather to
subsidize access for everybody so that
you close the potential genetic gaps
between people but also to recognize
that equality isn't everything
um you know I'm mini Chan I I mentioned
Nietzsche earlier in the conversation
and he saw equality as a kind of disease
of the West an unfortunate side effect
of Christianity Christianity did a lot
of great things for the west but it also
gave us this bizarre idea that all
hierarchy is bad that everyone is like
sort of morally equal
I think to some extent that's a healthy
thought you know we should we should be
protected equally under the law we
should regard each other with equal
respect but at the end of the day like
you know we shouldn't think like if if
some people are smarter than others or
more athletic like that's an evil and it
needs to be eradicated you've probably
heard of this this Kurt Vonnegut story
Harrison Bergeron
um and in Harrison Bergeron he envisions
a world it's 20 50 and he says finally
everybody is equal but
we start noticing wait a minute some
people can concentrate better than
others some are a little bit better
looking than others so they invent the
ministry of handicaps and what the the
minister who runs the ministry of
handicaps does is you know for the
really bright people he attaches a kind
of laser that like zops them every 20
seconds so they lose their train of
thought he breaks the noses of a really
attractive people and he hacks off the
legs right of people who are especially
athletic and this is supposed to be a
parable of equality run amok and I think
what this teaches us is look
it's there's a virtue in trying to
equalize access to technologies that
enable everyone to flourish
but there's also a vice of being
obsessed with equality and and when you
think about it one way this Vice could
manifest itself is as the very kind of
eugenics that we started off talking
about kind of Nazi Eugenics if you want
to force everyone to be equal I guess
you can but it would require like
massive government coercion and I don't
endorse that so I think like we should
enable the poor to use this we can't
stop the rich from doing it because
it'll go somewhere else to do it if we
try to stop them
and we should learn to live with
inequality and if we get inequalities
that are so big that we can't cooperate
anymore
this is not like my hope or my dream
this is just my prediction at that point
we essentially speciate in the same way
that chimpanzees are now different than
bonobos they're very closely related but
they actually behave pretty differently
bonobos are more peaceful than
chimpanzees and they basically don't
live together in common societies they
differentiate is that the future of
humanity probably is that a bad thing
like I don't know not necessarily unless
you think like exact equality of outcome
Equity as we call it now is somehow an
overriding virtue so you have a
prediction that a potential Downstream
future might be the runaway benefits of
this kind of Technology coupled with the
variability that you have in terms of
the raw materials that you're playing
with
could end up with different
strands different species of humans in
future
which would then be unable to mate with
each other if they chose to
yeah with one caveat I think they'd be
able to mate unless I mean this is
interesting right because you can be
very different you can be a Chihuahua
and a Great Dane and you may not want to
picture what that mating looks like but
it's how it's possible right they can
produce fertile offspring
um but they're very different in terms
of nature physicality and so on right so
we have all these dog breeds there's no
reason that humans I mean we already
have been like this right if you take a
pygmy in the African forest and compare
them with the Swede I mean pygmies are
like four feet tall and swedes are you
know six feet tall and we're pretty
different actually right and we've got
past ancestors right I mean we interbred
with neanderthals Europeans we Europeans
have you know what four percent on
average Neanderthal DNA in us right and
Neanderthals actually had big brains
they were probably more creative than
Homo sapiens in many ways but there were
other differences that we don't fully
understand
so I see it like that I think we will
diverge but probably will be able to
reproduce but you just
you just sort of tempted me with an idea
which is it's possible that if some
groups diverge phenotypically quite a
bit and they're a lot like I don't know
either smarter or more creative or more
athletic than others they might want to
genetically enhance their children such
that they're now genetically incapable
of reproducing with other humans and
then you really get runaway selection
right wow yeah you would have a an
almost like a a tribal lock-in that you
can have exactly going forward well this
this conversation kind of reminds me a
little bit of
um Catherine page Harden's book the
genetic lottery so behavioral geneticist
but somebody who's from very strongly
from the left and I was fascinated by
this because it's those two things don't
tend to go together tremendously well
because they Clash up against each other
and obviously if you go down the
behavioral genetics rabbit hole for long
enough and you say okay well in a world
in which we managed to flatten all
um equality of access problems in terms
of the environment what you end up with
is an even more brutal World in which
the only difference is that anybody has
are exclusively due to their genetics
and that feels like even more that feels
even less meritocratic and you go okay
but if you do the reverse and you
flatten everything genetically you end
up with environment playing such an
unbelievably huge impact in terms of any
divergences that people have that that
doesn't seem good either so I mean I
don't know I don't know what the answer
is there that being said we mentioned
this again at the beginning some people
don't believe in behavioral genetics or
even if it's only explicitly rather than
implicitly they don't like the idea of
heritability playing a massive role
how hard do you think these people are
going to be hit by the world of genetic
enhancement when it becomes widespread
very and I think I think what's going to
happen is
you know right now the these these facts
are basically known and we can do
surveys too I mean if you if you pull
parents with two or more children even
the uh uneducated I mean people who
didn't go to university that's not
necessarily uneducated in a real sense
but not formally educated their beliefs
are far more accurate about heritability
than the average sociology professor at
an ivy league university right who
believe like men are only more
aggressive than women because they're
taught to be you know toxically
masculine or whatever right so a lot of
the elites actually have patently absurd
beliefs and right now there's not a cost
to expressing those beliefs There's an
actual benefit right you promote Equity
right by by spouting [__]
on the other hand when these
Technologies are available I think
they're going to use them I mean at some
point they are right they might be more
skeptical at first they might denounce
them
and again there's going to be more and
more cognitive dissonance created and
the question is can they just
continually increase the amount of
cognitive dissonance and publicly do one
thing and privately do another or is it
going to put so much pressure on their
world view
that we're going to get a kind of sea
change of of public opinion on this and
the answer is I don't know I'm I'm not a
prophet um but I think what happens is
like a lot of social norms and beliefs
are one kind of social Norm right it's
not the belief that the sky is blue
everyone believes that because you know
you have to navigate reality to get
around to leave your house but some of
these higher level beliefs about like
heritability which really are rooted in
political ideology
um those you can afford to get wrong
especially when you're publicly
pronouncing things
but you can't afford to get them wrong
in your private decisions or else you're
going to lose in the arms race that we
just talked about and so again I think
at some point there's going to be
pressure to change these beliefs and
once some of the elites change these
beliefs
and do it publicly I think there's going
to be a Cascade where everyone just goes
well of course I believe that all along
right of course heredity matters of
course mate selection matters and of
course these things are highly heritable
and we should take these accounts we
reproduce but in the meantime in the
interim I think there's just going to be
this this flurry of like a the science
doesn't work B uh it's immoral and
they're just gonna cast a bunch of
different arguments and see which sticks
and the reality is like we can actually
sort of we can really quantify like the
extent to which this does work what we
know and don't know we've given
perfectly good Arguments for and against
this and those are interesting arguments
to have
um but I think it's going to take a
while for for the elites to have these
and to come to grips with reality so I
don't know let's give it a 10-year
20-year time Horizon I don't know
do you think that this changes the moral
impetus for people to have children
it's a good question I think ivg will
because of it if it becomes possible for
you to have a kid in your 40s I think
it's more likely that some women who
regret not having children will
so there's going to be more control over
the quality and quantity of kids you
have
that's not always good though I think
that what we need in the west I think
we're in deep [__] because of the um
demographic Trends we're facing I think
Elon Musk is clearly right about this
and and East Asia it's actually even
worse there I think Korea the total
fertility rate hit 0.8 per couple this
year so that means their population is
going to let less than half in one
generation right they would go from like
5 million that's not the actual
population but hypothetically let's say
5 million to like 2.3 million in a
generation that's insane right play that
out for like three generations and Korea
disappears
so what we really need is like massive
cultural change I don't think this
technology is necessarily going to
facilitate that one direction or another
but um it is going to influence the
direction it takes I really don't know
especially one of the things that may be
selected for most likely to be selected
for would be intelligence
yeah but intelligence is negatively
correlated with fertility or at least
with with birth birth rights yeah
yes and that could be a problem so right
as intelligence goes up income goes up
and that's because opportunity cost goes
up there's lots of fun [__] you can do
with your time rather than changing
diapers whatever and so that's a bit of
a parody of an argument but that's kind
of the economic analysis so the Richer
you are the less kids you have and
that's been mostly true but it's not
true in Israel
um it shows you Israel shows you even
among the secular wealthy Israelis
they're above replacement barely but
they are above replacement
um and what that shows you is like
nationalism religiosity things that
provide meaning in life can lead
fertility to go up even when education
and IQ is high and so I think what we
need is pretty massive cultural change
um I don't have any like magic formula
for how to get there but I think this is
the biggest crisis facing the West right
now is like how do we
how do we sort of move away from this
sense that the best thing you can do
with your life is pursue pleasure make
as much money as possible it's not the
pleasure and money are aren't good but
rather how do you transcend those things
and use them in the service of living a
meaningful life and part of a meaningful
life is like getting married and having
children and having friendships that
last across your lifetime like not just
buying the latest iPhone I think more
and more of us are realizing this is
like an extremely important question it
turns out Plato and Aristotle you know
sort of thought these things through
better than we did a long time ago
um but they were also anti-liberal and
anti-democratic so I don't know if we
can save kind of the the sort of liberal
democracy that we've had for the last
hundred years and also boost fertility
meaning in life Etc because liberalism
is premised on the idea that the
government's sole function is to protect
individual rights and to make no
judgments whatsoever on what a good life
is on whether we should have an overall
social goal social Vision Etc so I think
one of the biggest questions and I just
published a paper on this called can
liberalism last demographic demise in
the future of liberalism and maybe
controversially I came to the conclusion
that liberalism is evolutionarily
unstable
and that some form of nationalism or
religiosity might end up in the long run
replacing it because of this fertility
problem that that's outside of the scope
of genetic enhancement
but it may be that religious people or
nationalists who both Embrace High birth
rates and embrace some of this
technology are going to be the ones that
succeed over the next two to three
hundred years a society of Mormons and
Israelites perhaps I don't know Tech
friendly Mormons Israelis yeah
um and Israelis yeah yeah what's that
paper called because I want to read it
yeah that's can liberalism last is that
on whatever it's fill papers
yeah yeah it's there and I'll send you
like it's not a fish I mean I wrote it
like two years ago but you know Academia
works it's going to take another nine
months before it's like in print but
yeah it's done ready to go so yeah one
uh documentary that you should check out
is birth Gap with Stephen Shaw so I had
him on the show about three weeks ago uh
he I just placed him on Peterson's show
as well and he's absolutely smashed it
uh he is a data scientist who for the
last seven years has studied birth rate
decline worldwide uh and it's the most
comprehensive most accessible very easy
to to get into breakdown uh and it's a
three-part documentary the first part is
out and on YouTube and you can watch it
for free called birth Gap and then I had
him on the show and we spoke about this
and I agree man I think it's so so
strange that
um
I read
super intelligence by Nick Boston when
it first came out and then I read
um the precipice by Toby ORD it's one of
my five best books that I've ever read
my entire life no one talks about
Birthright decline or like demographic
collapse no one as an existential risk
yes I think I genuinely believe that to
get into the Super nerdy realm of like
what an existential risk is like
permanent unrecoverable collapse I don't
think that birth rate decline can
actually get us to permanent
unrecoverable collapse because for as
long as there's
thousand people you're probably still
sweet and there's definitely still going
to be a thousand Mormons and a thousand
you know blah blah blah blah
um but by way of functionally a very
large collapse or one that sets
civilization back especially if you're a
long-termist you know if you're will
mccaskill like you this this is the sort
of thing that should be spoken about and
I it it's just
creeping under the [__] radar and
because there's no smoke in the sky or
asteroid coming toward us or you know
gray goo paper clip AI takeover thing
that we're going to be faced with um it
doesn't Galvanize response in the same
sort of way no one cares no one gives a
[__] about it because it creeps up on
you one generation at a time
agree and what you just said made me
think of something I hadn't thought
about before you know marrying together
the sort of pronatalism or worries about
collapsing birth rates plus the
technology
um when you think about it like wanting
to have children is itself
um its own trait right so like
historically I mean partly kids are just
a product of sex I mean obviously right
that's why sex is fun that's the
darwinian explanation of why the
approximate and the ultimate coming
together yeah exactly right so you make
it the most pleasurable activity you can
and now we have these these proxies like
drugs and I mean video games are a
little different but drugs certainly and
these and porn all these distractions to
like get us away from reproducing
but here's an interesting thought that I
hadn't really thought of before and that
is that it may be that through this
genetic filter as populations start
declining especially in the west they
already have
um who survives well yeah the religious
people partly because of social
technology God tells you you should have
children it makes a positive virtue of
this
but then there's also people who just
happen to like kids right they just want
to have a bunch of freaking kids
and like that has to be partly heritable
it's not just completely arbitrary right
and those people are likely to
disproportionately reproduce and it may
be that in 50 to 100 years when this
technology is really developed and
people understand a lot more about genes
and heritability it may be that some
people deliberately uh program their
kids at the genetic level to want to
have more children and what a bizarre
outcome that would be
but it may be like yeah the the fertile
shall inherit the Earth but fertility is
partly going to be genetically encoded
like the desire to have fertility
selectedly fertile will inherit the
earth well exactly because he has
resources become more abundant and the
cost of reproducing goes down people who
just want to have more kids unless there
are laws against it will just have more
kids
so
one thing that I should have asked
before
is there an ethical concern
around you as a parent
choosing the traits of your child
yeah but I think that um the ethics Cuts
both ways so
um in Old argument from Michael sandel
at Harvard against using these
Technologies was hypothetical at the
time it's called the case against
Perfection it's a good article I've
assigned it to my students
um you know and they get convinced until
I give them another article then they
get convinced of the opposite View
you know what sandel says in the case
against Perfection is look there is a
virtue to accepting what you have and
working with what you have and yeah
becoming the best version of of what you
can be but like accepting that you have
these limitations and a problem with
using the technology would say
is it's going to lead parents to think
they could have like ultimate Mastery
over over what their children are and so
on that's true there is a virtue in like
being willing to accept your kids for
who they are even if you want to push
them a little bit but you know there's
also a virtue in not using this
technology and just sort of saying like
um I don't really care what traits my
kids have like they're gonna have to
just learn to live with that that's
cruel dude like we have really strong
evidence that you know if you have
cognitive empathy you're going to have
more friends right and be able to
succeed in your in your job if you have
more conscientiousness
if you're smart
and athletic you're going to be better
at sports because you can remember the
play calling of your coach and you can
anticipate the game theory of like if I
do this the other team will do that so
my best response to Nash equilibrium is
to do this other thing right if you're
if you're musical like the ability to
learn music quickly and to and to play
better depends on intelligence so
I think there are these like General
traits at least up to a point yeah I I
want to agree with you you don't want to
select for the extremes necessarily
General traits like a well-functioning
immune system cognitive empathy for
conscientiousness and general
intelligence that are going to be good
for any kind of kid you have and I would
say it's a virtue to actually actively
select in favor of those so sandel is
right we don't want to like pretend you
know we're going to have the perfect kid
and be super disappointed with how our
kids turn out but he's also wrong that
like we shouldn't try to deliberately
sculpt the shapes of our kid we Sorry
sculpt the traits of our kid we should
and there are some things we know no
matter what no matter what you're good
at it's generally better to have a
better memory to be able to creatively
solve problems whatever domain you end
up in that's going to be good for you
and so like we shouldn't just pretend
like we have no idea what makes for a
good life that's [__] of course we
have an idea it's not that you know
having a certain color of skin or
whatever that makes for a good life okay
no that's not true you know there's
going to be a diversity of preferences
some people want tan skin or darker skin
or lighter skin fine whatever
but the claim that
we don't have responsibilities or we
should deliberately select against
intelligence that's insane like we we
know that there are some traits that
tend to make a life go better
Jonathan anomaly ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out the stuff that
you do where should they go
uh my website so yeah they can find that
we'll include it I guess in the show
notes what's up for the people that
aren't going to write it down
yeah Jonathan Dash anomaly.com
perfect
yeah I tried to stay off of social media
for my own mental health and because so
many of my fellow academics have been
literally fired for things like what
they've said on Twitter or you know
censored in various ways so I stay on
social media but all of my all my
writings videos Etc on the website so
brilliant dude I really appreciate you
this is fascinating stuff thanks for
coming on it's a great opportunity I
love your show and so this is an honor
to to be on it so thanks what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
foreign